so the scientists strategy ignore Donald
Trump how long will that work I mean it
can't go that much longer I mean it's
getting crunch time it's under two years
well until they both step into a real
ring in South Carolina or one of the
primary States I think he can do that
until they actually step into the ring
by the way can we just put something to
bed for once and for all officially here
on the pbd podcast what episode number
is this
uh 224. can we just put this to bed Ron
DeSantis is running for president in
2024. can we stop with the charades
you're the leading candidate for
presidency of the United States the
whole charade of like well I'm committed
to Florida we'll see how it goes we're
past that when you've passed Donald
Trump and the current president of the
United States in the polling for the
likely favorite you're running for
presents so here's my question I'm
having trouble understanding can you
unpack that a little bit I'm saying that
Ron DeSantis is running for president
enough with the game and I forgot which
interview Pat that I saw where somebody
was like it's like going up what you
just said like he cannot this is that
you know that moment in your life this
is a he can't have a meeting and be like
all right Trump you be the president
they left you over no I'll be the vice
president right now is this is his
presidency that that is the strategy
working I mean the question is the
following guys let me go back to the
question is the strategy of ignoring
Donald Trump here's the question let's
stick to the question
strategy how long will it take for you
to ignore until you have to attack
um I think I think one more year I think
one more year and it's he's gonna get
the gloves are coming off I gave my
answer as soon as they both have to be
in a primary and they have to say
something to each other there's no I say
one year Pat one year then it's gonna be
bow what do you think he's gonna say
what what is the shot what's the first
shot fired from like the moment Kamala
went after biting in the debate
everybody was like oh [ __ ] yeah racist
or the moment I'm right here I'm right
here
or the moment or the moment who went
after Kamala with the uh with the uh
the moment after her campaign was over
that day right there when she went after
her absolutely okay okay you're done
Andrew Wang's off you're off next week
eight people yeah okay so how and what
is what is he going to attack what is he
going to attack the Santos yeah what is
gonna I got it tell me I mean he has to
thread this needle because he needs this
he needs Maga country in his corner but
he also has distinguishes himself it's
kind of like the conversation we just
had about the CEO board seat guy it says
Trump respect thank you for your service
you've done amazing jobs at the same
time
you've created this climate in this
country where Americans at each other's
throat
I want to be the person that unifies
America thank you for everything you've
done your policies everything you stand
for amazing I'm with you in your corner
but America is looking for something new
and something fresh and I think I can be
that person so Maga I know you're out
there I know you love Donald Trump I'm
with you I'm gonna take on the leftist
and the wokis I'm gonna be there for you
dude that's like the last thing he's
gonna say what do you mean what happened
to you what did you have for breakfast
today like you got to stop eating cereal
I learned through this new book Jenna's
meeting
because I actually think I'm spot on
Adam those eggs were bad
he has to what do you think he has to
walk a tightrope between balancing Maga
but also winning a general general
population what do you think
I think uh he he has to do counter so if
I'm sitting with him with the scientists
with around the centers I'm sitting
there saying instead of figuring out
what you're gonna say here's the 40
things that Trump's gonna say
how are you going to counter on which
ones are worthy of counter which ones
you deflect and you just move on with
okay so what is one thing a hundred
percent Trump is going to say to
DeSantis here's one thing he's going to
say
if I don't come and give that
endorsement he barely want governorship
without me he would never be Governor
right now Florida would have a
democratic so you're welcome Florida
he's going to say that okay okay you
would have lost to Andrew and by the way
by the way true just so you know it's a
story that's right yeah 100 he's right
okay
so that's 2016 though I mean it's a long
time ago it's going to be eight years
removed you could be right a hundred
years ago what's right is not about
history right is right okay hang on
that's right keep going so he's going to
say that and uh uh what's the
scientist's answer to that he has to say
I'm very grateful that you came out
you're right it was right so yes this is
the sentences right rebuttal me winning
the first election you had a lot to do
with it but me going from 34 000 Victory
to one and a half million that's me not
you 100 so that's powerful so that's how
powerful that he's got to go back and
forth I stood up to coved I responded to
this guess what the voter's gonna say
even Maga because everything's about he
needs to win the magazines he's not he
already has the Republican uh in his
vote but the mega vote the mag of vote
they're going to say it's gonna write
you know what I'm saying it's kind of
right he set up the Disney education he
responded to these disasters he kind of
did that yeah well listen everything
you're doing is pretty much the policies
that I would have done yeah for sure
he's just doing policy so he's kind of
like he's mimicking him copying
everything I did you know it's okay so
he's going to say well I give credit to
Great policies these policies those
policies these policies you were right
they were great policies what we did
different that you didn't do was this
policy this policy this policy and those
ended up working out in our favor but
yeah partially he's right there's the
policy they did right we were going to
duplicate and the ones we added here's
what we did okay but I've made this I've
done this I've done this so you don't
know what it is to do this you're right
I've never ran a multi-billion Dollar
business but the benefit I have is I
have proof to show that I was the
governor of the state that got the most
criticism over any other state in
America and I was the governor of the
state that stood behind parents stood
behind a mom stood behind homeschoolers
stood behind people that wanted a choice
stood behind those guys and we showed
that the right formula of how to react
under the pandemic the only the one that
led everybody else was the state of
Florida I get credit for that as the
governor of that state and that's given
me the credibility and a moral authority
to now run for office to be a America's
president so that's the second one then
he's gonna I mean he's gonna come back
what the scientist is not going to do
because the sentence is as much as he is
a very much of a counter you know what
do you call it counter puncher he he
also knows where not to go he's not
going to go family he's not going to go
kids they're going to try to get the
centers to talk about how do you feel
about the fact that the president's been
married three times he's not going to
say nothing they're going to try what do
you think about the you know the link to
this and link to that he's not going to
fall what if they bring up like how he
respond how he's gonna defend Trump
defend trouble okay he's gonna defense
right he's gonna defense right he is
going to defend Trump until it comes
down to him showing that I am my own man
got you that's what's going to happen
because because DeSantis is not a trump
mentored guy it's an indoors there's
those are two different things a
mentored requires loyalty and endorsed
is just thank you man I'm grateful I
appreciate you do you understand what
I'm saying the difference there's
there's mentor others indoors mentored
requires loyalty endorsed only requires
respect and thanks wow gratitude so the
sentence is not a dummy he's going to be
solid and Trump's going to play Trump
and uh I I uh I think
I there's no way in the world Trump's
all of a sudden going to turn into
saying this new guy that's not going to
go and do anything with them no the only
the only thing the only thing that could
happen is if the conversations lead to
something happening with the court that
it's going to be very very very very
ugly then DeSantis has a card yeah and
and you know what card that is what what
card is that if they go off the trumpet
I don't think you caught what I just
said are you gonna say it again let me
say one more stuff if notes impeachment
who gives a [ __ ] about him if they go
after him court-wise Trump trump yes
you're unelectable the classified
document stuff none of that if the stuff
is like because listen here's what's
going on with America man you know all
the [ __ ] that you're finding about Elon
Musk they're targeting him if you try to
Target anybody and use billions of
dollars of government resources and
lawyers you're going to find something
on everybody good luck hey America we
learned something today all of you guys
got some [ __ ] in your closet that you're
dealing with financially they can find
it okay if they want to Target you they
can Target you they can Target must they
can Target everybody okay
uh so Trump is the second most hated man
in America today the most hated
president living alive today he's number
one
and if they go after him they're going
to find a lot of things who's got 50
years of History taxes records a bunch
of different things deals
he's going to need the p word
he's going to need the p word when
somebody becomes a president
protection no yeah I got a different
keyword okay pardon wow yeah if it goes
that route
and it's just going to be like my first
position
one I'm pardoning this two let's get to
business and do what America needs to be
done okay no one's perfect here's a
pardon let's move on then he gets the
support then Trump can go golf and spend
the rest of time with us with his family
and all that other stuff again remember
what I said don't put words in my mouth
I said if the government keeps
investigating and trying to find [ __ ]
constantly over and over and over again
to make his life a living hell where for
the rest of his life he has to deal with
tax IRS [ __ ] [ __ ] he's
eventually going to be like listen man
just give me this I'm gonna go play golf
I'm gonna go hang out leave me alone let
me spend time my kids I didn't and I I
think this is going to hurt the
Republican party because think about Pat
you have these two Alphas that are going
to be at some point they're gonna lock
coins right I do think the scientist
could be a synergist you think so I do
think this sentence could be huge but so
do you think as a higher likelihood of
getting to this magic number I keep
talking about 60 approval rating Trump
or the sand the Santos is it even a
question no no not at all but what I'm
saying is I don't I don't solve for that
though but listen I don't that's an
indicator let me let me tell you
something you know
the the this guy like what what does
Trump truly believe in uh Trump no 100
and by the way capitalism by the way I'm
not even being a jerk by the way by the
way by the way just so you know you wish
you believed in yourself as much as
Trump believes in himself of course okay
yeah so don't ever judge a person that
believes in themselves as much as this
guy believes in themselves okay for a
guy to have the world after him and he
goes and golfs with pressure and people
making fun of him when he golfs and he
said did you see that drive did you see
how good it was did you get that are you
going to show that are you going to show
how good of a shot that was even with
you talking [ __ ] to me yeah there isn't
anybody in America today that can handle
the kind of pressure and hate and
mockery as that guy leaders bulletin
he's first on that list I'm with you on
that if I may there's a difference
between pride
and hubris be familiar remember we
learned all that in Greek mythology and
I think Trump is is is veering towards
more hubris Than Pride I'm you're 100
right we all wish we had the
self-confidence but it veers towards
hubris I may have lived a life that many
like if you want to like uh think about
a Great Gatsby type of a movie to see
who's lived a Crazy Life
I don't know bro put who's lived a
crazier life than a better life but he's
denying that you're absolutely right so
absolutely all I'm saying to you is if
if I want to have somebody go up against
Killers yeah dirty ugly mother you know
like legit people like that I'm sending
him let me ask you one more thing I'm
sending Trump I'm sending him if I if I
want somebody that's a
um
you know from like you know the other
day uh uh I saw a clip by Obama Obama's
like you know they say uh Barack uh you
know he cannot uh handle Putin and and
uh you know he is afraid of Putin and
they say things like this about me well
I mean if you're talking about you're
gonna handle Putin better than I will
my Canon my opponent you know the the
person that's saying all this stuff
about me he can't even know how to
handle CNBC moderators and then you hear
the crowds ah yeah and then they show
the clip the first time Trump means
Putin and he pulls Putin in Yankton and
you're like whoa yeah that that guy's a
former KGB no and and Alpha is Alpha
that was felt within a second there is
no question there so the the point is if
you want somebody to go in places like
that to handle people like that
immediate
it's the other guy that's the most hated
president alive today but the scientists
is going to be the one that's going to
do similar job
with lesser fewer controversy added
baggage all the other stuff that comes
with it and a smaller Target because
quite frankly he's not the personality
that Trump is he's not the Entertainer
that Trump is he's not uh uh a character
that Trump is but
he will make a very good president yeah
I think the centers will make a very
very good president so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]